[Music]
so you have a small team
i'm sure very capable hyper capable
people you have a small team
within
the safe scope of let's just call it
climate solutions or technologies that
have that are both attractive in and of
their own
right for various reasons but have some
let's just call it beneficial impact on
the circumstances we find ourselves in
how do you
apply constraints to that so you have
positive constraints that you've applied
elsewhere in the company in terms of
total head count and various other
ways that you've
applied constraints
how do you choose your targets and make
sure that you have a a focus how do you
eliminate things
well first is it's a wide funnel so it
really is based on do they have a cool
mission are we curious about the
technology is this something that's
important is this a really big market or
a really big problem that is solving
something for let's say the climate
crisis and it could be anything so it's
not just materials or just
petrochemicals or carbon capture we look
across everything so because frankly at
the end of the day the reason why we do
this is because we love to learn and
you got to really understand the systems
thinking as opposed to just one thing if
you're really going to solve the
problems we have so we like to look
broad
very broad
both from a technology perspective value
change perspective as well as regional
perspective or country based so we look
at all this and that's just
how many cycles we have to learn and how
many people bring us interesting ideas
so that's kind of the top of the funnel
but as we narrow down there's a few
things one is
can this be deployed on mass
in the next 10 years
and is it going to be disruptive is it
going to be like we talked about that
the switch you know that from the the
vacuum to the transistor but this
electrical distribution
mem switch
it is can be applied to so many things
along the way and it's so disruptive
we're like that needs to exist when it's
disruptive and not just evolutionary but
it's going to change the players on top
it's going to change the products
fundamentally it's going to bring a
win-win-win for the environment as well
and customers as well as the
manufacturers that's when we see big
gains like we're talking about the
motors as well
so we want something with disruptive
wide impact because that's what it's
going to take to help fix this planet we
can't just have little there's no silver
bullet for this we've created so many
different systems over the last 150
years most of them
almost all of them have even been
thought about in a circular fashion you
know and how to get the trash or how to
make it more efficient it's just like oh
it works
but it works for that business not for
the planet for us as a society so those
are the kind of things that we really
look to and that's how we narrow that
funnel so that's the first thing is does
the technology is it disruptive is it
close to being marketable you know is it
close to being a product the third thing
is
and this is one of the most important
things that we've learned across all of
our portfolios is there a way that we
can quickly scale
so because we have to we have to reboot
the planet this is not just oh we gotta
go we'll do one industry in this one
state or somewhere in this country we're
talking about when we said classic
problem it's around the world when we
talk about energy and efficiency it's
around the world so if you have
something
we want to see the disruptive technology
that it's it meets it's it's it meets a
lot of needs and can be out of the lab
and into people's lives within 10 years
in a mass scale and do you have the
technology for scale in other words
a lot of times when we see well we don't
want to just hear about your one factory
what is your scale plan for making a
hundred of these factories so we can
quickly deploy them around the world
right
how can we get this stuff moved quickly
to to every corner of the planet because
we all have these problems so i think
those are the three fundamental things
that helped us to narrow that funnel
down and then there's obviously the
financial terms and if we can help and
you know all the other stuff but the big
the broad strokes are really those three
things
all right so i'm gonna dig dig a little
deeper on this and i just want to
mention briefly and i can never
pronounce his last name maybe you can
maybe you can get it right but rather
than butcher it chamoth most people know
who i'm talking about when i say chimas
sure chamath yeah has said you know the
first trillionaire in the world is
someone who's going to fix climate
change or greatly contribute to climate
change uh so there's a lot of there i do
think
having just watched kind of the sea
change in the last few years there's
there's some really some tremendous
tremendous opportunities
for for just let's just call it
cold-blooded capitalists who want a
great return on investment
there are there are many technologies
and solutions being developed now that
that
if we're talking about direct consumer
or
products that consumers use the
consumers will choose over alternatives
so i think it's become really
exciting
on the playing field
you mentioned now there are certain
things that i would say are
seem obvious and get discussed a lot so
let's just say adoption of solar maybe
subsidies from the government such that
we have less dependence on
on fossil fuels and foreign especially
foreign
energy
but
i had never
realized as you described that so much
energy was lost just due to
inefficiencies from point a to sort of
point z
what are some of the
uncrowded or underestimated
targets let's just say or areas related
to climate change that you you think
people should pay more attention to
there is what you can do personally and
there's what it can be done
professionally and if we look at you
know obviously there's evs and doing the
right thing there and doing the
recycling and composting and all the
right stuff at home and not you know
reuse don't buy all new so there's all
those kinds of consumer facing things
that need to happen but it's really
incumbent on the innovators the
companies the individuals in the world
to bring new solutions to consumers or
change out the system without the
customers even knowing yeah to make
things more efficient because customers
don't know that 60 of all the energy
created in the world is lost what can
they do about it it just shows up so we
have to go and reboot our infrastructure
in some ways and so in many ways in
almost every way
and so
there's one for me that we're now
finally getting into which is the
hydrogen economy
so if we think about all these different
chemicals that we use today
are come out of petroleum
okay they come out from sucking
something out of the ground and then
refining it what have you plastics is
one of them
we can move to
hydrogen based economy
to create all of those products we can
create them more quickly with
no or little co2
get this similar products out
and they're actually more profitable to
be made for the companies themselves so
there's all of these things around
hydrogen like let's give you fertilizer
okay it doesn't sound sexy but we need a
lot of fertilizer in this world now
there's other ways of tackling that too
but fertilizer is a huge one concrete is
another one concrete's huge yeah
steel another one right thermal just
creating thermal you know thermals like
high temperature steam and those kinds
of things for different industrial
processes today we burn coal natural gas
or whatever
we could do it with hydrogen or we can
do with electricity right
that whole area see is unloved people
are starting to work on it they're
starting to make starting to make
inroads there but we need a lot more
work on those things
it's not just electric cars it's not
just the things that you hear about in
the in the press every day
so i think that we need to be really
thinking about the hydrogen economy and
to a certain extent the biomass economy
because we can actually turn a lot of
the the things we use today like let's
say jet fuel those can come from bio
sources trash sores this is not edible
sources but really trash or waste and
turn those into things that can stay
carbon neutral it's not a perfect
solution because we're using things on
the on the ground in the on the planet
right biomass but it's just sitting
there and it's going to turn into you
know co2 or methane we can put it back
in and use those things now and we have
lots of technologies to do that so i
think hydrogen economy biomass economy
not chopping down trees and just
lighting up smoke that's not what i'm
talking about here i'm saying
transforming it into chemicals and raw
materials so that they can be used not
just burning wood you know which we see
a lot of people
fudging that they say that's clean
energy it's not
you